the russia collusion story we spent
three years living through and covering
turned out to be a hoax
in fact it was perhaps the greatest
fraud ever perpetrated in american
politics how did it start
well in part with something called the
steele dossier that turned out to be
opposition research put together by a
british spy called christopher steele
who was christopher steele well no one
ever heard of christopher steele
and yet everyone believed him
immediately
the allegations in this christopher
steele dossier and you went through the
timeline very well
a few moments ago are stunning they're
actually substantial portions of what
was in the steele dossier which was a
raw intelligence document
that have indeed checked out based on
our own reporting and word from numerous
official sources
the dossier in fact is far from bogus i
think we're going to actually have to
stop
calling it the infamous dossier
increasingly it's the accurate dossier
based on our reporting liars
now they've been exposed as liars the
whole story has been memory hold you
don't hear a word about the steele
dossier
barry meyer has written a new book
though that examines that dossier and
the broader relationships between
journalists and the intelligence
community the book is called spooked
the trump dossier black cube and the
rise of private spies he joins us now
barry thanks so much
for coming on it dawns me this is an
hour-long conversation
that we really should be having but in
the next short period of time
tell us the connection between the
intelligence community globally
and american journalists how how broad
is it
how big is this well
it's very big tucker and thanks very
much for having me on to start with
uh so journalists get information from
all kinds of places they get it from
traditional intelligence agencies like
the cia they get it from law enforcement
agencies
like the fbi but what i really focus on
in the book
is this booming growing role of
private intelligence firms or as or
private spies
as i call them and you know this
industry has
exploded in the past decade and their
connections with journalists have
exploded along with it
i mean if you're reporting out a story
one of one of your concerns is being
used by the people feeding you the
information for some purpose you're not
aware of
it seems like this arrangement is
particularly vulnerable to that
it should be your first and foremost uh
concern as a journalist
you know my i at the times where i spent
most of my career
i did health and safety reporting i was
a reporter that first broke the story
about oxycontin
and it's illegal marketing and when drug
companies were making claims
you as a reporter would scrutinize them
unfortunately in the case of the dossier
in other situations
we have reporters who aren't giving
these claims the same level of scrutiny
and as a result this thing kind of
metastasized on its own
yeah buzzfeed just printed it flat out
without vetting any of it why do you
think that is
what what has changed that intel
services private
or government can just feed information
and then see it in print
yeah i think it's a result of several
factors you know there's been a
tremendous growth
uh within the media there's been a
fracturing of it there
are you know extremes on on on either
end politically
uh of the media arc and so you know
there's a great appetite for scoops you
know every once everyone wants to claim
that something's new we have some
intelligence we
we have something fresh that no one else
uh
has and as a result this becomes you
know a petri dish
for these private intelligence firms to
kind of feed information
you know the reporting that you're doing
on this you know we should have been
reading about for the past year this
seems really important and i hope that
we talk again barry meyer appreciate it
congratulations on the book
i greatly appreciate it tucker thanks
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else